these trucks stretching to the Horizon
are only a fraction of the 5.5 million
that entered Laredo Texas in 2022 it's
one sign of a broader shift in the
global economy as hundreds of companies
around the world move their
manufacturing from China to here in
Mexico and as a Border Town that makes
Laredo The Hub at the center of a trend
that's changing Global markets if you
are Manufacturing in Mexico you can get
that product to the U.S consumer in
under 24 hours in the truck if you are
Manufacturing in Asia it's going to take
you two to six weeks amid an explosion
of trade between Mexico and the rest of
North America here's a look at why
Laredo is primed to become one of the
world's most important land ports and
its role in transforming Global Supply
chains
on this bridge dividing the U.S from
Mexico trucks often wait hours for a
chance to cross into Laredo in 2022 more
than 800 million dollars worth of
products from Auto Parts to carpets to
avocados passed through the city each
day according to U.S census data the
total trade between Mexico and the
United States 40 percent of that crosses
through the port of Laredo Daniel
covarrubias has spent years studying
laredo's role in international trade at
Texas A M International University if
you see on a map where Laredo situated
between the United States the biggest
Market in the world and Mexico one of
the biggest producing markets in the
world well it's right in the middle of
it Laredo is uniquely positioned to
handle all this trade as more and more
companies reduce their dependence on
Chinese factories and shipped production
to Mexico
part of a larger strategy called near
Shoring it went from a trend of
globalization to regionalization
economists
missing rates a trade war between
political uncertainty caused by Russia's
invasion of Ukraine helped fuel the
nearshoring trend
plus Mexico's free trade deals mean
companies that make their products in
Mexico can ship them to the rest of
North America duty-free you're seeing
Chinese companies to get out of the
tariffs and post on them well they can
come and take advantage of the U.S
Mexico Canada trade agreement if they
manufacture in Mexico
in 2022 Goods traded between the U.S and
Mexico reached almost 780 billion
dollars an increase of nearly 18 percent
from the previous year while Laredo
isn't the only U.S border Town
capitalizing on the expansion of near
Shoring it's receiving the most activity
in October 2022 about 27 billion dollars
worth of freight moved through Laredo
alone that month it overtook the trade
volume from each of the ocean ports of
Los Angeles and Long Beach
Executives say part of laredo's appeal
is its location the city is the closest
U.S landport to some of Mexico's largest
manufacturing centers like the Nuevo
Leon region which includes the massive
industrial city of Monterey from loading
up on a truck in Monterey you have a two
and a half hour drive north from
Monterey until you hit the Laredo border
Tom Simmons is the vice president of
majestic Realty a privately owned
industrial real estate developer over
the last 10 years Majestic has invested
in Warehouse properties across Laredo
that product will get unpacked in a
Laredo Warehouse like we're sitting in
right now we'll get repacked into
outbound trucks and tractors and will
get distributed throughout the United
States and you'll have all of the
roadway networks that will spread East
and West the expansion of trade in
Laredo is fueled by The Surge of foreign
direct investment in Mexico over the
last two decades Mattel expanded its
Monterey plant into its largest
manufacturing facility worldwide Lego
also operates its largest Factory in
Nuevo Leon with plans to expand and
Tesla recently announced plans to build
out a massive gigafactory in the
Monterey region and those are just a
small sample of companies relocating
their operations the Mexican Government
said more than 400 companies have shown
interest in moving production from Asia
to Mexico that translates into a surge
of products funneled into Logistics hubs
like Laredo if you take a 35 mile radius
and place it here on this cross-border
region of Laredo Laredo you're going to
find upwards of 500 U.S custom Brokers
and Mexican custom Brokers firms you're
going to find more than 500
Transportation companies more than 350
logistics companies that concentration
of logistics companies means trucks
and lots of them more than 15 000 trucks
cross daily by the port of Laredo and
this is between two Bridges the World
Trade bridge and the Columbia Bridge the
amount of trucks passing through Laredo
has seen a steady increase over the last
10 years to keep up large infrastructure
build-outs are underway the city has
already committed to expanding the World
Trade Bridge from eight Lanes to 16. and
the rail company Canadian Pacific Kansas
City broke ground on a project that will
double the capacity of a rail Bridge
spanning the Rio Grande more trade
passing through Laredo also means
greater demand for warehouse space in
this Warehouse thousands of auto parts
are transported in and out by truck each
day
just one lot over trucks flatten the
ground to make room for even more
facilities we're adjusting to the supply
and demand imbalance right now with the
simple answer of just build this site is
just one example of the more than 3.8
million square feet of warehouse space
under construction in Laredo that
amounts to a 28 increase in space since
2012. according to CoStar our real
estate analytics firm but with
warehouses more than 97 occupied
companies are struggling to keep up with
demand it is actually an unhealthy
Market because there are a lot of
businesses in this market that want to
grow
as manufacturing shifts South of the
Border it is creating job opportunities
in the U.S that's because components for
certain equipment are often made in
Mexico but need a more skilled labor
force for final assembly the automotive
and the electronic will oftentimes go
back and forth across the Mexico and U.S
border four five six times before the
finished product is finally ready for
the U.S consumer while the boom and
trade between the U.S and Mexico might
mean a smaller slice of the pie for
China Executives and economists say it
will still remain a dominant supplier
for a vast range of goods
in the meantime the trade passing
through Laredo is projected to grow with
the numbers and data tell us is that the
port of Laredo is going to keep on
growing it's just so in a league in by
itself compared to other ports of Entry
is going to be hard to compete with
Laredo
[Music]
foreign